Now, everyone, before we move on to the resolution, I would like to take a few words from the command of the newly established unit. Thanks
to you, we are still
alive today.
Thanks to the efforts of the legendary samurai heroes, that
silver screen is probably alive.  The people gathered here are
all those who know the secrets of national defense, and your part
considers it to be more than just a fairy tale.You
and the Republic's skill experiment werewolves, the operation to
exterminate 100,000 Werewolves, and the Africa Mil
regime's attempt to stop the refugee massacre.  And to
stop the explosion of vampire infections in Eastern Europe, the world
owes you a debt that can never be repaid by a catastrophe that threatens to blow away the foundations of the world.So, if you will
spare me the burden and listen to me for three minutes,
of course.
But before that, please sign here and
take a picture with me.